now instead of focusing on hey what can
we do to save the economy which the
democrats and biden have basically
destroyed we're all going to be
screaming about abortion and ironically
we're not even going to be screaming
about the honest issues related to
abortion we're just going to be
screaming whether abortion is legal or
not which again has nothing to do
with roe v wade so now i want to link
this to those good liberals because
these are the people now that are that
i focus on them a lot but really in some
ways they're going to be the key group
now they're going to be the key group
because they've been on their way to
going in the right direction but they
might fall back because of abortion
these are the people that biden needs
needs more than anything else
so you might remember or no this is just
a few days ago
this is jo bill maher and i know i play
a lot of bill maher eclipse but i think
you get why i do it uh this is bill
maher who keeps getting sort of most of
the things right two years late uh
talking about how bad the democrats have
been on the economy
the democrats they are in trouble the
economy shrank the last quarter we
didn't see that coming and you know when
it shrinks two quarters in a row that's
a recession plus we have horrible
inflation sometimes you get the feeling
the democrats are tanking on purpose to
get a better draft pick next year
i
i mean
inflation
yes right and food and rent have you
seen the price of chimneys they are
through the roof
that joke had been lying around for
hundreds of years nobody picked it up i
i picked it up
okay
so you see he's getting it
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] happening and
he's making jokes about it they got like
20 writers for that chimney joke pretty
good okay fine um now this is the same
bill maher who unfortunately voted for
biden encouraged his
viewers to vote for biden and of course
you may remember this clip that i don't
think he wants people to see anymore
this is when that orange man was
president and mar wanted a recession
because that would take out that orange
man right josh isn't the fed cutting
rates now just going to make the next
economic downturn worse what's your
prediction i've been hoping for a
recession people hate me for it but it
would get rid of trump so you shouldn't
hate me for it i mean recessions are
really bad people lose their jobs i know
and we shouldn't wish it's worth it but
uh i i don't i mean a recession is
always possible i don't see any
particular reason to think that it's
likely i think you know really aren't we
overdue for one just no this by the
cycle of economics this is such a
misconception people sort of feel like
oh you know well about every eight years
or something you're supposed to have it
recessions don't come because they're
due recessions come because there's some
sort of overheating something goes wrong
in the economy
so he wanted a recession when it was
going to get rid of the guy that he
hated then he gets the guy he wants and
we're basically gonna have a recession
so once again you're just always late to
the party um and i guess it's easy to
call for a recession when you probably
have 100 million bucks i don't know how
much he has but it's more than anyone
watching this right now or the me
so you can you can weather the storm on
a recession but now they're realizing
how bad it is but that's why this thing
with the abortion thing is is so nuts
because was the whole
machine just handed something that is
going to push everybody back into their
old way of thinking about everything so
it's like man
mar you're right on inflation you're
right on how bad biden has been you're
right on free speech with him you're
right on all the woke stuff and crt and
the gender stuff but is this going to
push those liberals back to the left and
the real question is to go back to his
joke you know he was basically saying
hey are the democrats tanking it so that
they can get a better pick in next
year's draft well you know what bill and
this is the question man okay let's
pretend it's next year's draft you know
what next year's draft is 2024 it's most
likely desantis on one side and it's
most likely kamala on one side right
because it's not going to be biden so
let's say it's desantis or trump
or tim scott
or literally any republican
who are you going to vote for who are
you going to draft and i know you're
going to draft the wrong guy because i
basically have given up with you but i
haven't given up on the people that
watch you so that really is the problem
they might be tanking it they might be
tanking it intentionally because i think
they want to destroy the system but are
you just going to always make jokes
about the things that you help screw up
two years later
this is what all the liberals have to
figure out